foreign
[Music]
are you kidding me what an Ant-Man
sacrifice himself oh my gosh stupid Iron
Man
he's just in a movie theater being an
[ __ ] oh my God no [ __ ] way
foreign
I chose you Iron Man of everybody
do you mind if I wield do you mind if I
wheeled for a bit just like a couple
practice Wheels
I just saw you guys you guys are firing
me up a bit you just sort of you want to
keep your hand adjusting it straight on
[Laughter]
the headlock you wanna
foreign
never fall for that in battle never fall
for that
if you ever want to like come practice
wielding just I could grab your number
if you want like me and you could just
practice wielding together I'm more of a
Lord of the Rings kind of guy but I know
you guys are into Star Wars yeah I mean
people have called me Legolas like
sure okay let's do it
[Music]
I'm speaking nice to meet you vice
president yeah just hit me up when you
want to wield
[Music]
the funniest part about that is that you
know that those dudes are all just like
praying that one day she sleeps with
them oh and so that he's just like comes
up makes fun of it grabs her number and
then he's like
I'm waiting on yeah a couple of my
friends they're coming but um I think
they're just taking a little long so I'm
just gonna order some drinks for them
Mikey likes Coke Sean likes Sprite and
Jacob likes Coke too and then the rest
will just do Waters
thank you yeah Mikey's gonna like that
they're definitely coming though because
it's my birthday but um I guess maybe
yeah no they're definitely gonna come
because they wouldn't miss my birthday
where'd you get this dinosaur balloon oh
I bought it from The Party Store yeah
it's my birthday today my 16th birthday
thank you just waiting on your gift yeah
they're coming Mikey and the boys
Mikey's bringing all the boys so yeah
he's my best friend my son's a big daddy
to our person is he yeah I love I [ __ ]
with T-Rexes a lot I love T-Rexes I used
to be a brontosaurus kind of guy and
then I went through a Stegosaurus phase
two but now I'm back on T-Rex's
Velociraptors they're overrated they're
[ __ ] they're coming I swear they
would not there's no way they'd miss my
birthday like I know Mikey um I'll
probably just get like an appetizer
because I know Sean likes the sampler so
I'll just grab a sampler
I think Mikey likes boneless so I'll get
boneless yeah
oh Jared likes Caribbean Jerk we'll
definitely do that he'll love that when
he shows up he's gonna show up soon I
got all the boys coming
[Music]
I don't know what to do because they're
the boys are [ __ ] loafing right now
like it's been what how long has it been
because there's I don't think they'd
missed my birthday you know like you
know blueface yeah me and Mikey just I
just went to a blue face concert with
him like thought Tiana live it was
[ __ ] lit so like I don't know why he
wouldn't just show up sorry about that
man I'm just I'm just a little upset
like before your birthday I don't know
like Mikey and the boys were supposed to
come so I know what would you do as a
server in this situation would you would
you give him like his thing for free if
you genuinely believed it or would you
just be like you'd take the drinks off
because sodas don't really matter what
would you do you don't really have that
power as a server you have to talk to
the manager in an individual place you
gotta the owner's usually there so you
as a server I would do what these people
were doing you go over you talk to them
feel sorry for them walk to the back and
go dude I feel so bad for this guy you
know you can then maybe if you're if
you're in a restaurant where there's
kindness and people are nice go to the
manager the owner and be like dude like
this is [ __ ] up this can we just let
this guy go like it is also depending on
the night in the restaurant this looks
like there's some other empty tables and
it's fine but like if this guy's taking
up a table of one two three four five
six a 14 top or at least the 12th top 12
to 14 top and it's a busy night you kind
of want to kill them too no yeah because
because that's a big table where you
could be making a lot of money on and
you're not gonna make any money yeah I
feel you but they're being very sweet to
him
you were at blue face too I actually had
a table in the back oh oh my God he's
calling me yo Mikey where are you guys
at I was just about to pay you guys are
coming dude what do you mean you're not
coming you're supposed to be my friend
you're not even going to come on my
birthday
like I ordered a table for all the boys
man like I got you and Sean and
Caribbean Jerk like Sean loves Caribbean
Jared what do you mean we're not even
friends
you don't come to my birthday dude I
took you to Blue we went to blue face
together what do you mean you only went
to blueface because I paid
well guess what to you Mikey screw you
we're not friends anymore
how about that
she's got a kid and guess what I slammed
your sister so how about that Mikey is
there any way you could shove my Molly
up your ass and bring it into the
festival for me
it's only it's only a half gram oh
you're nauseous yeah a little Molly a
bass can help that actually I would
bring it in but I have the Molly [ __ ] so
I'm just like [ __ ] all day so I
can't bring it in and I'm not trying to
not roll in the festival you know like
Ari's on tonight and [ __ ] who that guy
yeah he's not gonna do it is that he
looks like he has a tight ass
you look like you have a more looser ass
that's why I asked but you can't
all right this poor guy is probably like
like so [ __ ] up just like dried he's
holding on for the fence for dear life
yeah you're right oh get the [ __ ] away
from me because like a sober guy would
be like are you get back it the [ __ ] up
lunatic you know and yeah that you're so
right that's so fun so fun you also put
on my finger guard thank you man uh
middle finger yeah very sensitive though
cause I've been like fingering girls and
[ __ ] too and the bowling ball
what are you doing
thank you sorry
[Music]
man sorry
man what's your handicap nine point
something 9.6 don't lie to me man 9.6
yeah you don't look like you break 100
though
8.6 you're probably faking that though
hey Bob I got a liar in the golf section
he said his handicap's 8.6 but there's
no way I can't eat for Trump once that's
too bad paid me in hookers don't tell
anyone though I signed an NDA but I
can't wait till they just finally
legalize bestiality
you know what I mean like it's no one's
business
like what I do with my dog and a jar of
peanut butter that's nobody's business
but my own you know it's pretty good
this is way funnier than speed no I'm
sorry this yeah this guy like I just
said I want to go on the road with this
guy like yes clearly this is hilarious
so funny this guy is too much you
already lost
you guys carry oh
ready watch this
oh foul foul foul foul dude that was a
foul I touched the ball first
imagine you're at a Dick's resort trying
to buy something in this the worker is
just dribbling in front of you non-stop
fine with this
imagine this poor guy just ordered
pretzels he's probably hungry just
[ __ ] so just slugging up
we were at the bar right across from
this place and we went
Dan what have you eaten today
yeah
like did you eat Chipotle or any like
beans or anything like that you ate
Chipotle yeah what'd you get what do you
want like did you eat double chicken or
like like you know a dutch oven no like
you rip ass and then you pull the sheets
over
and cover me and like I just [ __ ]
inhale that [ __ ] like you fart
yeah you rip good ass
yeah can you rip like a tester or no
I want to but I want an authentic Dutch
oven like I know you guys are famous for
your fries
I know what if she couldn't fart I'll do
whatever you get a refund did she would
have [ __ ] the bed if it meant keeping
that 150 bucks do you have another pair
of [ __ ] gloves by any chance because my
hands are like hurting in this oh these
no man yeah
where'd you get those uh these are
guided like uh
even Target maybe like not even 10 bucks
huh in the women's section or no in the
men's section oh okay are you looking
for the women's ones or no no I just
thought only girls wear those
what are you afraid of the calluses or
I like your hair Supermarket go straight
right turn right on Terence turn left on
buy a [ __ ] tour or don't ask me
stupid questions Street okay
that's how you get there
I'm not here to [ __ ] answer questions
about that buy a tour
or get out of my face guys anyone want
to go on a tour
there's one back there
um no basically I'm really into the
cognitive sciences and stuff like I'm
very like interested in it but I'm kind
of worried how it's going to apply to my
like my future like real life skills you
know because basically like if you guys
don't know like I'm an up-and-coming
rapper basically like yeah
yeah I know yeah 21 21 Savage is
basically like my spirit animal and [ __ ]
but um yeah
no no I just like
yeah
because you said dreaming like I'm a big
dreamer like Lil Uzi even favored one of
my tweets so
it's just it's a good question like real
life skills are important guys like
we're in college but we gotta learn you
know so do you think like
if I'm like and I'm like a street rapper
like I trap like I'm not faking [ __ ] so
like do you think this course is really
for me like
um
you know what guys
I'm done
I'm dropping out of school I'm done I'm
not a raven anymore who's with me who's
with me let's do it bro
oh my God College was not this fun
nothing this fun ever happened in any of
my classes this is not my this is a
customer's car I'm just filling it up
because I'm a pump boy you know yeah
usually I pump rods but can you just
show me how to do so no I don't so I
hold this so take this out
okay there we go okay so I hold it like
this yeah no so take it out
oh [ __ ]
put it inside there put it inside don't
smoke no oh [ __ ] what do I do what do I
do
get out there you go help me help me
[ __ ] dude my boss is gonna kill me put
it back what do I do with the customer
can I tell him it was you
I'm gonna tell him it was you in the
green shirt it's something else all
right he's the best hilarious he's the
best what do you give Kyle one to ten
ten ten ten I laughed my ass off the
whole time and I want I'm gonna [ __ ]
go and lay in bed tonight and watch this
[ __ ] and Tick Tock all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
you join the Discord in my description
you can put videos for us to react to
there
[Music]
[Music]